und sich dann zu anderen video ist
wahrscheinlich an meiner freunde ich bin
zurück aus dem urlaub ich war die
letzten zwölf tage zusammen in einem
kleinem oder max an der nordsee aber
jetzt bin ich wieder zurück und bin
wieder da für euch leute
und ja es gibt ja was da müssen wir mal
drüber reden und zwar habe ich natürlich
nicht als ich im urlaub komplett alles
außer acht gelassen und gar nicht mehr
auf social media nachgeschaut nein ich
war auf insider massiv unter anderem und
hab gesehen dass ihr mir ein video
geschickt habe mit der bitte dass ich
darauf reagieren soll
dieses video stammt von rebecca wing
denn rebecca will hat jetzt wieder einen
neuen internet trennt aufgegabelt denen
sie natürlich auch übernimmt und auf
ihrem kanal auf putzt und erstmal zu
analysieren werden bis heute das video
rufe fock i aus toy story vier niemals
um drei uhr nachts über facetime an
anschauen
ganz kurz dazu ich hab selber mal
gegoogelt musste ich weil ich nicht
wusste was es ist stellt sich heraus
hockey ist ein gipfel also gabel und
löffel in einem der sieht so aus und
scheinbar ist der sind so aus und
scheinbar ist das jetzt der neue trend
dass man videos mit einem gipfel macht
leute ohne witz ich bin kurz davor bei
meinem internet provider anzurufen und
einfach meine internet zu bestellen weil
die sache so das level das jetzt
erreicht haben wir reden einfach mit
gipfeln okay aber wir schauen mit ok
also ja leute unsere becky ist wieder da
ist wieder am start mit einer neuen drei
uhr nachts challenge diesmal redet sie
nicht mit puppen oder mit was auch immer
11 und der chef ist und auch nicht mit
dem game master
nein denn das internet dreht sich weiter
leute und heutzutage redet man mit
besteck nicht mit besteck niemals um
drei uhr nachts mit besteck neue
verfluchte nummer okay rebecca wo
findest du eigentlich die verfluchten
nummern
den verfluchten telefonbuch oder gibts
dafür irgendwie internetseite so kriegst
du dir sagt dass das selbstverständlich
soll ja okay ich hab ne neue verbuchte
nummer gefunden
was soll ist eine verfluchte nummer also
jetzt ich habe eine neue nummer gefunden
ohne mist jetzt ohne mist okay rowling
hat eine verfluchte nummer gefunden okay
ganz ehrlich leute ich will es gar nicht
mehr so irgendwie hören dass leute sich
über sie lustig machen oder sie nicht
ernst nehmen glaubt ihr einfach mal okay
sie hat ins verfluchte telefonbuch
geschaut oder die verfluchte auskunft
angerufen und hat sich eine neue
versuchte nummer geben lassen und mit
dieser mit dieser neuen verfluchten
nummer telefoniert sie jetzt mit besteck
ich bin gespannt
ohne mist jetzt ich habe eine neue
nummer gefunden die man angeblich nicht
um drei uhr nachts anrufen soll sonst
passieren wichtig seltsame dinge ich bin
mir gar nicht sicher
diese videos schießen wollte ich muss
schon sagen sie du und du hältst mich
echt schon ziemlich gut ist schon geil
okay also becker hat bei der verfluchten
hotline angerufen hat so gesagt 'junge
habt ihr vielleicht ein neuer versuch
nummer für mich diese natürlich
selbstverständlich aber ganz wichtig
rufen sie niemals um drei uhr nachts
eine neue nummern gefunden die man
angeblich nicht um drei uhr nachts
anrufen soll sonst passieren richtig
seltsame der sonst passieren richtig
seltsam aber ganz schmal sind was sie
gesagt hat so wenn man diese nummer um
drei uhr nachts anruft dann redet man
mit besteck ok also nicht nur mit
besteck es ist nicht so als würde ich
mir zugabe aus der küche und
tatsächliche physische gabe mit der
reden nein
man rede mit einem gipfel ja also einem
besteck stück dem irgendwelche
eigenschaften zugeschrieben werden das
scheinbar eine persönlichkeit hat ja
also internet 2009/10 macht sich noch
irgendwann gedanken darüber ob das was
wir machen geistig gesund ist von volker
aus toy story 4
also dass die sache irgendwie dass jetzt
ein neuer trend also wir wissen ja alle
wie das läuft eigentlich nur leute also
es kommt irgendwelchen trends in den usa
hoch so war es bestimmt mit elf
unterstellt game master annabelle oder
so also welche trends kommen den usa
hoch weil da sind die leute noch geistig
behinderter als bei uns hier in
deutschland bewegen
das macht einfach die gleichen videos
dann halt auf deutsch und ja natürlich
kommen wir denn da hin wo wir jetzt sind
dass sie jetzt ich muss es einfach noch
mal sagen einen gipfel auch facetime
anrufs irgendwie neues spielzeug also
eigentlich kein richtiges spielzeug aus
den neuen toy story film ist nämlich
eine gabel die irgendwie so
zusammengebastelt wurde falsch ein
gipfel sondern mischung aus gabel und
löffel ist es keine grippe kommen
solltest du vielleicht wissen bevor du
dich in die gefahr begibst das ding
nachts um drei anzurufen
neues spielzeug geworden und ja die
einfach nur creepy aus und ich weiß auf
jeden fall mega verflucht sein
man wollte die info dass die nummer
verflucht ist also ok also gut du hast
sie aus dem versuchten telefon
wahrscheinlich also ich kann nur raten
also wahrscheinlich noch die nummer des
besuchten telefonbuch seinen liegt
natürlich nahe dass die verflucht ist
aber ich habe mir wirklich noch die
frage so wie sieht das so aus dass du in
produkten telefonbuch so okay das war's
okay ich schaue mal versteckt aber okay
da steht irgendwen weist dabei nicht
nachts um drei anrufen naja ok dann
rufen wir dann erst mal noch zum 3 ich
weiß aber nicht ob die funktionieren
wird ich hoffe es weil ich habe so lange
gegoogelt
ich habe überall geschaut und immer mal
landete ich auf ebenso komischen seite
okay jetzt muss sparen leute jetzt
erzählt sie uns augenscheinlich wie sie
auf diese nummer gekommen ist bzw
also ja natürlich nicht in wirklichkeit
aber in wirklichkeit hat sie einfach
irgendeine freund von sich angerufen und
dann hat er diesen ford ka in die kamera
gehalten oder so aber ist zumindest mal
interessant zu hören wo in ihrer
fantasiewelt die nummer hergekommen ist
und irgendwann mal landet sich auf
irgendwelche komischen seite mit dieser
nummer und dort meinen leuchtet das sei
die echte verfluchte nummer sie soll
funktionieren
rebecca offiziell kannst mir die seite
mal schicken also ich würde ja unter dem
video kommentieren und sagen hat einer
vielleicht die webseite mit den
versuchten nummern so
ich kenne ich schon mal rufen aber ich
bin ja leider blockiert werde ich kann
es mir einfach ins programm schreiben
soll
ich werde einfach auch mal eine
verfluchte nummer anrufen bitte 42 und
ich werde jetzt die zeit sinnvoll nutzen
erst mal googeln was man vielleicht
hockey nicht fragen solche vielleicht
auch ein kurzer hinweis dafür dass leute
also ich würde wirklich geld drauf
wetten dass rebecca ring nicht
vielleicht so wird kein einziges mal
seitdem sie diese videos macht bis
nachts um drei wach geblieben ist und
wieso videos aufzunehmen also ich gehe
mal was sie machen wird sie setzt so ein
17 uhr hin macht ihre rollläden runter
stellt die eu auf ihrem handy vor und
dann ja und tut so als 38 ok also schon
mal gibt es in diesem handbuch oder wo
auch immer diese wo man herkommt
hinweise dafür was man fragen darf bzw
nicht frage darf wenn man dieses stück
besteck anruft okay was ich nicht
verstehe ist warum ist fortier also
diese gabe dieser gipfel eigentlich ein
bösewicht das wasser kam habe ich die
spicker dem scheuen tier ist es noch mal
leute das ding sieht doch eigentlich
voll lieb aus wobei hätte auf dem bild
gerade seine eltern in der hand menschen
nicht abstoßen kann alles zum spiel
zurück werden okay das ist vielleicht
ein bisschen besser gewählt als wenn man
jetzt sagt so bist du ein richtiges
spielzeug war er ist ja nur eine gabel
ich glaube ja das ist ja allgemein
bekannt auch gute punkt von der bäcker
an der stelle ist allgemein bekannt dass
es nicht zum guten ton gehört wenn man
mit besteck spricht das ja vorkommen da
man redet immer mit einem löffel oder
zum buttermesser oder sowas passiert ja
auf jeden fall so sagen will ist wenn
man mit diesem besteck spricht gilt es
als sehr unhöflich mit dem besteck so zu
reden als wärs ein spielzeug scheinbar
scheinbar macht man das nicht hat er
glaube ich einen zugang zu nummer
anderem wissen als wir so
ich wüsste jetzt nicht was die logos
sind wenn ich mit besteck geräte
hey das ist einfach voll süß aus alter
wie zur hölle ist das zu einem bösewicht
geworden dass es so gut aus sprang ein
stück vor leute ruft jetzt vorprescht
und ich glaube ich spreche für uns alle
wenn ich sage dass ich sehr gespannt
[Musik]
über den faktor hinweg dass es ist
wirklich also ja man muss das immer
wieder vor augen halte nicht besuchen
weil ich diese videos machen wir das vor
augen zu halten das ist einfach 2009/10
und wir sind auf youtube an der kunden
ankommen dass wir mit besteck facetime
ja muss ich einfach nur der stelle
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
rockig so youtube-star das ist ein
problem das die handynummer von irgendwo
her bekannt wird dann geht ihr um und
alle zuschauer rufen an
so ist es jetzt gerade für kinder ich
will einfach nur seine ruhe okay er hat
den stressigen alltag ihr wissen für das
ist ein gipfel zu seinem jahr 2019 das
nicht leicht du bist ja dann kommt man
auch zum harten gipfel arbeitstag nach
hause
es wurde super mit einem gelöffelt es
wurde salaten mit einem aufgespießt und
zum mund geführt ok wisst ihr was man
isst einfach fertig so mein bildschirm
was passiert rebecca ihn rufen an
nachts um drei bretter nachtruhe hallo
ich habe deine nummer außen internet
gefunden bist du bist du wirklich vor
wie diese gabe lovestory 47 soll man
dich ja nicht anrufe aber eins zu eins
so wird es aussehen wenn jetzt
irgendwann wenn so ein elfjähriges
ferngehalten immer von baby bekommen
würde und dann die anrufen würde
hey bist du wirklich baby ja
vielleicht verstanden was ich kann ich
kann es eigentlich fast nicht darauf
reagiere
nein ich wollte ich beleidige nein aber
du bist doch eine gabel ein klassemann
das leider stellen wir auf uns wirken
leute rebecca wegen diskutiert jetzt in
einem youtube-video mit 85.000 aufrufen
per facetime mit einer gabel darüber ob
sie ein spielzeug ist oder nicht so
göppel
mit einem löffel ja ok einfach mal so
stehen lassen einfach mal drüber
nachdenken
also ja und dann klingelt natürlich
nachher noch und rebecca in content ist
nummer 2 schlägt zu also das erste ding
was rebecca wegner macht ist nachts um
drei sachen anrufen
das zweite ist sie lässt sich von ihrem
freund oder kumpel irgendwas für die
haus zu stellen
[Musik]
in dem fall ist jetzt ein hockeyspiel
zeug und damit schließt sich der kreis
der vollkommen geistigen verwirrung an
der stelle werdet mal kreativ und in den
kommentaren scheint mir ein was eure
diaz mit der nächste gegenstand sein mit
dem übergang nach den drei facetime
obwohl sie es nicht bis dahin könnt ihr
hier einfach ich persönlich
vorstellungsvideo und hier könnt ihr
einen kanal abonnieren wenn euch dieses
video gefallen hat ich danke euch für
zuschauer nicht fürs auge
macht's gut